pour assurer la protection d'une espèce
il faut savoir où se trouvent les
populations et avant une idée de leur
nombre mais dans le cas du narval un
mammifère marin qui vit dans l'arctique
obtenir ses informations pourtant de
base n'étaient pas toujours chose facile
heureusement l'intelligence artificielle
vient désormais ou secours des
chercheurs
[Musique]
les neuf ans on peut justement les
trouver dans l'océan arctique si on veut
vraiment les voir c'est seulement l'été
pendant l'hiver ils sont plus dans
milieu de la glace il fait noir était
fois je pense qu elle pas beaucoup de
monde sur la planchette qui vous déjà vu
un arval
[Musique]
avec sa défense en spirale le narval
marque l'imaginaire chaque été la
chercheuse marianne marcoux se rend dans
l'arctique pour étudier les mammifères
marins elles analysent leur répartition
et leurs déplacements pour mieux gérer
les populations
au canada on a deux populations d'un
arva on a la plus grosse population
monde qui se tient dans la dans le
détroit de davis qui a entre la terre de
baffin le groenland donc facile vers
l'or qui pendant l'été ils viennent dans
les fjords du canada et du groenland
c'est surtout dans l'article de l'est
donc où nous n'avions qu'un autre
population qui est dans la dans le nord
la déduction
en 2017 on comptait environ 170 mille
narval dans l'arctique canadien dont
plus de 90% dans la baie de baffin
mais avec la fonte des glaces et
l'augmentation du trafic maritime qui
s'ensuit les baleines qui fréquentent
ces eaux sont de plus en plus menacé
[Musique]
on connaît très peu finalement le nombre
de collisions qui peut exister parce que
des fois c'est pas du tout détecter ça
arrive la nuit il ya des cas où mon bar
pour une baleine échouée par la suite ou
à la surface quand combat qu'on va
pouvoir observer où malheureusement des
fois ça va rester allons rester sur la
coque avant du bateau
par exemple les bateaux de la mine de
fer mary river sur l'île de batz fin au
nunavut passe au milieu de l'habitat des
narvals
or la compagnie veut doubler sa
production ce qui augmenterait
considérablement le transport maritime
et les impacts sur les mammifères marins
la plus gros défi avec les bateaux et
les narvals c'est le bruit ça ne peut
masquer leur communication s'appuie tout
simplement les dérange et ça peut aussi
les déplacer peuvent carrément décidé de
quitter un lieu aussi être au bruit à
cette menace s'ajoute celle de la chasse
traditionnelle des inuits le narval est
chassé pour l'ivoire de sa défense et
pour sa viande le mactac non inuits
donné à la peau et aux gras des baleines
[Musique]
c'est une chasse qui est
durable mais une grosse partie civile on
travaille c'est de donner des avis
scientifiques pour qu'on soit capable de
bien gérer la chasse de ces baleines
d'où l'importance de bien connaître le
nombre et la répartition de ces
mammifères marins
ça c'est un groupe avec 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
probablement vite mal parce qu'on voit 8
baleine avec leur défense selon le port
s'avère très simple comme ça mais c'est
quand même assez compliqué les baleines
y bouge il publie pas juste en dessous
de l'eau
les narvals ne se laisse pas facilement
approcher
l'observation erin devient alors
indispensable pour faire des relevés de
population
les yeux rivés sur la surface de l'eau
des observateurs comptent les baleines à
bord d'un petit avion
c'est la façon traditionnelle de faire
et on sait encore souvent mais
maintenant ce qu'on a commencé à faire
de plus influent c'est quand même temps
au même qu'à mes erreurs dans l'avion
qui prend des photos directement en
dessous du tracé de l'avion pour
retourner à des analyses qui regarde les
photos sur des grands écrans de haute
définition qui doivent passer toutes les
photos en zoom qui regardaient dans
toutes les parties fotolog mais ça
manque beaucoup beaucoup de travail donc
chaque photo ça peut prendre plusieurs
minutes peut-être même heure tout
dépendant combien de baleines regardez
cette photo là pour détecter les
baleines dans les photos les biologistes
bertrand sharif et emilie charrette ici
on justement eu à compter en main des
centaines de narval sur des milliers de
photos
on passait à travers des images
aériennes sur l'écran à la main est bon
on n'a pas besoin de passer à travers
six milles pour se dire
une façon plus efficace pour passer à
travers tout ça d'une façon plus rapide
et puis standard ise aussi mais en
parlant avec des gens pour essayer de
trouver si une solution existait déjà on
s'est aperçu que dans plein de domaines
y avait il y avait le même problème
alors avec bertrand s'est dit bon écoute
on va creuser un petit peu et puis merci
que aînés
l'entreprise wall seeker propose un
outil de détection automatique des
baleines par intelligence artificielle à
partir d'imagés aériennes alors le prix
le premier défi c'était que deux
biologistes
rencontre quelqu'un en intelligence
artificielle c'est que c'était le
premier défi que heureusement on a
rencontré antoine au parc h à
partir de milliers d'imagés environ nous
on commence à avoir des bons résultats
puis les modèles intelligence
artificielle c'est ce qu'ils font plus
tu en donnes pluie apprend donc plus tu
fourni de données plus il va apprendre
de façon précise à reconnaître qu est-ce
qui est une baleine de caisse qui n'est
pas
je peux emmener à 11000 je crois il
faudrait jeu sera ajouté à peu près une
base de mes scénarios à 20000 et 30000
sa
trente mille baleines ça pourrait être
pas mal
pour alimenter l'algorithme ils ont
collecté des milliers de photographies
prises à partir de drones et d'avions on
reçoit les images de notre client et
puis on passe à travers ce système qui
est de lia avec un humain qui s'appelle
yume no doubt et tous les cas où
l'algorithme n'est pas sûr donc les
hedge crise qui renvoie ça à un humain
un expert est cette personne là dit oui
ça c'est une baleine ça c'est pas une
baleine on voit ça à l'algorithme et ça
apprend comme ça c'est pour ça aussi que
notre base de données et notre dada sets
d'entraînement a tellement de valeur est
tellement bon parce que y'a juste et
biologiste marin qui l'on a noté
celle ci le seclinois qui connut envoyé
que deux
médians jouer avec la musique et puis
voilà quatre
notre algorithme c'est une séquence de
couches de neurones qui au début du
modèle reconnaissent des petits patins a
donc peut-être un but que plus on avance
dans le modèle plus il va apprendre à
reconnaître des personnes complexe
l'algorithme sera mise à jour en continu
et la prochaine étape consistera à
traiter des images captées à partir de
bateaux et de satellites
notre avoir à voir ce qu'ils en étaient
capables de voir qu'on peut voir non
seulement des bélugas mais aussi des
narvals ça n'a pas encore été fait c'est
vraiment excitant parce qu'on n'était
pas sûr donc c'est plus clair il ya des
quelques travaux qui ont été faits par
d'autres équipes pour sur des plus
grandes halles elle cet outil de
localisation des baleines devrait
permettre de mieux les protéger les
applications sont multiples il y a le
gouvernement qui a comme lors leur
travail de
préserver d'avoir un plan de management
pour pour toutes les baleines dans l'or
dans leur zone il y a aussi les
compagnies de consultation
environnementale qui que ils ont besoin
de faire des impacts d'étude d'impact
les autorités portuaires et les navires
veulent aussi éviter les collisions les
groupes de conservation eux s'en
servirait pour étudier les baleines et
les sociétés pétrolières lors de leur
tête seesmic parce qu'elles doivent
s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas de
mammifères marins dans les environs
[Musique]
l'algorithme sera accessible à tout le
monde sous des conditions éthiques
précise mais ce n'est pas sans danger on
veut pas que wayne seekers servent à
contourner des lois
l'environnement ou
servent aux chasseurs de baleines d'être
beaucoup plus efficace par exemple en
plus protéger les mammifères marins cet
outil permettra de mieux connaître les
baleines difficilement accessible du
lointain arctique
[Musique]